pop quiz which of these five options do
you think could be removed from the
Majin Buu saga without affecting its
ending at all the correct answer is all
of them
let's fix them you know Dragon Ball
super still gets a lot of flack these
days for being poorly written totally
inconsistent and just all of these but I
still think is easier to watch then the
Buu saga and as some of you might know I
wrote a video a while back breaking down
the problems that I had with that very
saga in it I tried to communicate what I
thought the suck itself was not good
using as many film examples and literary
sources as I could find in order to help
bolster my point of view and honestly I
didn't expect to see so many people
agree with me so seeing as I've outlined
plenty of fundamental problems with the
Majin Buu saga already let's go one step
further and rewrite the entire thing
I'm always criticizing and analyzing how
stories are written so this should be a
fun exercise that said I do have three
rules
I want to abide by first rule number one
I can't invent or introduce characters
that were not in the boo saga
this means no movie characters and
nothing from Dragon Ball super like
where's or Wiese rule number two
I must finish the arc story in the very
same place that ended in the original
meaning Goku Vegeta and everyone
celebrating at the look after all the
events have concluded and finally rule
number three
Gohan needs to be the main character
this is gonna be difficult
alright so essentially the purpose of
this rewrite is twofold firstly I want
to remove the padding of the story
allowing for better use of its
characters and mechanics while keeping
the story focused and not as long as it
currently is secondly and finally I want
to give Gohan a good story it's not good
a crescendo like it did in the cellar
but I want to give him an emotional
journey that has a payoff in other words
I want him to be the main character of
this arc and boy do I have my work cut
out for me let's begin one of my biggest
issues with this section of the manga
came in its beginning reintroducing
Gohan as a young man is great and all
but the plot that follows is so
unbelievably uneventful and entirely
unnecessary for the story it hurts
these characters don't matter and the
secret identity of Gohan never really
plays into how the story unfolds in a
meaningful way the same goes for Gohan's
adventures saving the city
his school life in general the only
thing of value that came out of this
entire section that lasted was Vidal and
even she didn't play a large role in the
plot overall so what am I gonna do about
this instead of skipping over the seven
years that have passed in an instance
since the Cell Games I'd like to show
over the course of a minute or two
Gohan's life growing up without Goku
around to show chichi working hard to
raise him goat ends birth showing how
they as a family miss him and most
importantly to show go on shouldering
more and more responsibilities as he
gets older becoming the Earth's
protector I want to show him nervously
moving into public school finally
meeting and befriending Vidal similar to
how ups opening sequence communicated
the emotional journey Carl and Ellie
underwent I'd like to show the story of
God trying to fill the shoes Goku left
as the Earth's defender finally meeting
a new friend in Vidal helping teach her
to fly and for her to become one of the
only people in his life that can help
ground him the opening sequence comes to
an end as we fade into the present day
Goten is waking up in his room a single
day before the 25th Tenkaichi Budokai
outside his bedroom window Goten hears
the sounds of fighting shooting up from
his bed with a smile on his face he runs
over to his calendar market with an X
only one more day
Goten says excited he looks outside go
on his training with his eyes shut it's
at this moment we cut to Gohan's point
of view we fall right into the middle of
a fight between cell and Gohan he's
reliving that very fight seven years ago
beat for beat to finish the fight Gohan
tightens his fists and launches towards
cell inches before he makes contact
everything goes black and we hear the
words followed by a scream the camera
switches to go tens view as he runs from
the bedroom to the front door and
outside only to find Gohan on the floor
trembling as he runs over the check and
his brother
Gohan explodes onto his feet and rump
ting into Super Saiyan two electricity
shooting everywhere with his hand
millimeters from his brother's face
scared and shocked
Goten falls to the ground go on quickly
calms down and comes to his senses
lately go on has been suffering from a
series of increasingly intense panic
attacks a very human problem Goten asks
if he still wants to train go on
enthusiastically says absolutely he
takes a few minutes explaining the image
training technique and on his first try
go 10 picks it up like
that remarkably quick quicker than Gohan
ever had as the tube begins sparing
Gohan is again taken aback by how quick
Goten has improved over the last number
of months
Goten you've gotten amazing what have
you been doing while I was away well I
watch you whenever you train and I just
do that
the two brothers share a laugh and
continue fighting into the night before
being called in by chichi after all they
have a big day tomorrow
has the two walk into the house Goten
asks reservedly - Gohan what if I don't
know what to say go on looks down
perplexed what if you don't know what to
say - who - dad what should I say Gohan
smiles and gets down on one knee next to
go Tim and gives them a hug listen goes
him you don't have anything to worry
about mom and I will be right there I'm
certain dad will be really excited to
finally meet you
besides you two have a lot in common we
do sure you do and if you get nervous
just ask him if he's been training he'll
want to teach you a few things I then go
tense face lights up you mean it of
course I do alive or dead dad lives for
that kind of stuff with an excited -
goat in zips into his room go on and
chichi share a smile as the scene cuts
to the gravity chamber with Vegeta this
is where we will introduce trunks and
reintroduce Vegeta I love the scene
where the two spar together and I want
to keep it with one major change since
the sella games Vegeta has been
intensely affected by the death of Goku
interlaced with his training in the
chamber I want to splice in flashback
images of his return from the games
Bulma tried to support him and how
trunks saw all of this unfold as he grew
up we then cut the trunks his point of
view as he works up the courage to talk
to his father since the news broke that
Goku will be returning for the
tournament he's been much more
approachable the scene plays out much
like it does in the original vision in
trunks make a bet if he could hit him
that he will take him to the park the
major difference that I was talking
about is that trunks cannot turn Super
Saiyan in fact later Goten nor trunks
have ever turned Super Saiyan because of
this trunks fails to land that one shot
but does come very close on one occasion
with that the scene shifts it's
tournament day from this point I want
the beginning of the tournament date to
remain somewhat similar to the original
the first interaction between Goku and
Goten is adorable and incredibly
endearing I would just extend it
slightly as Goten is in his father's
arms
he says 'gone said that you did a lot of
training while you're away did you learn
anything amazing
Gohan winks at Goten with a thumbs up as
Goku excited stats showing Goten
some stuff that he
while this is happening we are
reintroduced to the old gang from here
Allah remains the same again Vegeta and
Goku draw each other in the standings
Goten and Trunks fight in the finals of
the junior tournament and embarrass mr.
Satan in the process however there is
again no Super Saiyan transformations
from other competitor in the original
story piccolo gave up against the
Supreme Kai and go on had his energy
stolen in my version piccolo won't fight
against shin he will instead be the one
to get his energy stored as Gohan looks
on his breathing starts to get erratic
once again Goku notices and says take it
easy Gohan as piccolo struggles for life
Gohan is greeted by a flashback of
piccolo dying in defensively suddenly
his hair begins to flicker and glow
Goku shouts not yet Gohan as the orphan
piccolo begins to fade he hears that
voice once again in an instant Gohan
explodes into Super Saiyan with the
electricity cutting through the walls of
the arena he lunges toward piccolo but
something's wrong his arms are numb and
his heart is racing
before he reaches piccolo Popovich and
llamó take advantage of the situation
stealing both Gohan and Piccolo's energy
leaving them both drained and
unconscious before flying off as Gohan
comes to he's covered in a cold sweat
with Vidal gently holding his head you
were talking in your sleep what's going
on something's not right
Gohan jumps to his feet well where's
piccolo what happened I think a better
question is what happened to you huh I
taught you better than that it looked
like you were tripping over your own
shadow
Gohan looks over to piccolo confused and
silent the del explains the situation
that piccolo had voluntarily given his
energy in order to aid the Supreme Kai
that everyone has already left to follow
spot OVA chin llamo and that he lost
control
piccolo finishes the conversation by
saying you're in no fit state to fight
maybe you should sit this one out as he
flies off piccolo remarks to himself
come on go on
we're counting on you Gohan readies
himself to follow piccolo Vidal stands
in front of them where do you think
you're going I just told you what
happened what if you don't come back I
always come back
I always come back with that Gohan
launched into the sky after piccolo as
Gohan flies towards the group he notices
Piccolo's energy suddenly disappear what
he touches down he arrives just in time
to follow Goku and Vegeta into poverty
ship where's piccolo Gohan asks Vegeta
grunts and Goku remains silent you
should have come here Gohan but now that
you are I need you to follow my lead
do you hear me the rest proceeds pretty
much as normal with one major change
Gohan wants to fight the ships warriors
but Goku insists that he stay on the
sidelines Vegeta fights poopy Goku
fights yacon and instead of Gohan
fighting Tabora this is where Majin
Vegeta is born immediately they are
transported to the tournament grounds
where we witness Vegeta's ruthlessness
firsthand trunks looks on in disbelief
with a smirk on his face Vegeta raises
his arm once again this time pointing to
the other side of the arena as he begins
to charge the blast something snaps in
trunks causing him to dash towards his
father Vegeta sees him coming however
time slows down as we see Vegeta take
aim at trunks mere feet before the to
make contact a surge of golden energy
explodes in a blinding flash of light
around trunks when the smoke clears
trunks is revealed to have turned super
saiyan Vegeta now knocked back one
single step begins to bleed from his
mouth Vegeta isn't shocked immediately
lashing back knocking the boy out cold
with a conflicted expression painted
right across his face he wipes the blood
from his mouth spits in the ground and
shouts Kakarot what do you say now you
got it just take us back to the ship
Baba T once away from civilization go to
his force to explain the situation to
Gohan he explains that de Bora turned
piccolo to stone and that he is now
responsible for bringing piccolo back to
life through defeating de Bora with that
Goku leads Vegeta to the wastelands
where it all began
now the Goku Vegeta fight I will not
touch it's a masterpiece and needs to
happen however the fight between Gohan
and devorah I'm gonna change drastically
instead of going on struggling against
this enemy now that he has a singular
clear goal in mind despite him not being
100% he will obliterate Devorah from the
fights beginning to his conclusion to
Bora will go from intimidating and
confident to overwhelmed
terrified by Gohan as the fight nears
its end we see that Goten and Trunks are
on their way to the action as de bourree
lays beaten to a pulp
he begins apologizing to poverty for not
getting the energy needed to awaken
majin buu bhavati smiles this new one is
most impressive we cut to Vegeta's fight
with Goku as he is overwhelming the
Saiyan massive flashes of light
enveloped the horizon Goku is in trouble
Goten and Trunks see this and recognize
it's their fathers energies Gohan
notices the lights show on the horizon
also and as de Bora struggles back to
his feet Gohan powers up to full slowly
raising his hand out in front of him de
Bora begins to speak but is immediately
cut off as he is erased from the face of
the earth but Gohan didn't fire he's
confused as he lifts his head he sees
the pink monstrosity majin buu has been
released and Gohan can sense his
father's energy plummeting Goku knows
that he doesn't have much time the more
energy he puts out the less time he has
in the living world but he has a plan
abruptly Goku begins racing a top speed
towards commies lookout perhaps there
Vegeta will agree to continue this fight
in the chamber perhaps inside there his
time in the living world would be
extended sensing his father's losing
effort go on at top speed rockets to his
father's rescue flying away from majin
buu however it's no use
Buu appears in front of the young san
and with a single punch sends go on
crashing to the ground below struggling
back to his feet
Gohan fires an enormous blast through
majin buu before flying again in the
direction of his father by the time
Vegeta and Goku have reached the lookout
so too the fight has reached his
conclusion the same way it did in the
original Goku appealed to Vegeta
humanity before being knocked out by the
same prints as Vegeta prepares to fight
majin buu Gohan arrives the lookout to
see his father like motionless on the
floor well what did you talk that moment
a blast hits Gohan's back knock him to
the floor in a daze as Gohan lies there
semi-conscious Vegeta begins his battle
with Majin Buu the battle proceeds
precisely like it did in the original
only this time it takes place at belukha
and what
the same as the original Goten and
Trunks arrived on the scene however
unlike the original Goku regains
consciousness
aiding vegeta in his effort against
majin buu and despite their combined
efforts in their weakened state they are
still no match for him as Gohan lies
there with his eyes shut drifting in and
out of consciousness he hears snippets
of a conversation between Goku and
Vegeta 4,500 stances
mirror images of one another another
index fingers converge 30 minutes majin
buu however is too great for the two
Saints immediately knocking Goku to the
floor in a bloody heat as Gohan regains
his composure barely conscious and very
injured he sees his father blazing
beaten by Vegeta who is standing over
Gohan confused and distressed says to
himself up again without warning he
sends a blast straight through vegeta
sternum as the Saiyan Prince falls to
the floor
Goten and Trunks dashed to his side to
try to help it's at this time Goku picks
himself up off the floor
Gohan what did you do confused and
disorientated Gohan looks to his father
when he's struck by a massive blast from
majin buu Gohan is unconscious barely
clinging to life
seeing this Goku begins to power up with
all the strength that he has left when
suddenly he vanishes back to Otherworld
this catches majin buu off guard and as
he looks for where go ku went he sees
Goten and Trunks
dragging Gohan into the room of spirit
and time closing the door in seeing this
majin buu begins to charge towards the
room when suddenly booth an energy blast
beats him to it destroying the doorway
altogether no one can get in and no one
can get out
Buu begins to turn his head slowly there
at the edge of the lookout Vegeta lays
on the floor smirking good good job boys
barely making it to his feet Vegeta
begins to taunt boo what's the matter
you didn't think a simple blast like
that would be enough to stop me come on
give me a challenge with that Vegeta
begins to fall from the edge of the
lookout pursued by an incensed majin buu
and in a blinding flash of light Vegeta
sacrifices himself and says goodbye to
his loved ones
the last shot we see he confused Goten
and Trunks standing inside the room of
spirit and time with an unconscious
badly injured go
as the door of the room begins to fade
away I hate to leave things on a
cliffhanger but there was way too much
to cover in a single video and this
seemed like a perfect place to end it
don't forget to rate this video leave a
comment or you think the story might go
next and part 2 will be out next week
see you then